[Music]
the weekend spotted making a sneaky exit
from Bella Hadid New York apartment how
do you feel about feedback with Bella
multiple reports claim the axis who
dated for nearly two years have been
hanging out again but aren't officially
back on
are you happy to reconcile with her
according to sources the weekend reached
out to his former girlfriend after the
split from Selena Gomez last month
cleaners also seemingly gone back to her
old ways and has been spending lots of
time with her ex Justin Bieber she
watched him play pick-up hockey last
night and even brought her cute little
dogs along to the game and to complete
the love hat trick
remember we Justin was reportedly dating
model hailey Baldwin well now she's been
romantically linked to Shawn Mendes cuz
I know I can see you
both stars attended the MTV European
Music Awards this past weekend and spent
lots of time together at the after-party
where they snap this pic with Rita Ora
according to onlookers at the bash Shaun
and Hailey were inseparable and spent
the whole night in true European style
french kissing